the son of a former Saudi intelligence
officer says his family is being
targeted in a bid to force his father to
return to the kingdom according to the
New York Times sorrel Jabari has been
feeling for his life since moving to
Canada in 2017
his son halide told the newspaper that
his brother sister and uncle haven't
been seen since they were arrested by
Saudi security forces in March
the report says SAR dog job reworked in
the interior ministry for nearly 40
years and he was the right-hand man for
Prince Mohammed bin Nayef the
conference's cousin NIF was arrested in
March a partly because even complaining
about the Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman Sardar jobless son told the New
York Times but the Crown Prince known as
MBS feared the former intelligence
officer knew too much
since MBS became Crown Prince in 2017
several well-known critics have gone
missing
Saudi journalist Jamarcus Raji was
killed in the kingdom's embassy in
Turkey in 2018 the CIA says the crown
prince ordered the operation Gulf
affairs analyst sigell no bar says the
detentions are tarnishing Saudi Arabia's
international reputation the algebra
saga if we may call it so it's just the
latest example of senior members of both
the Saudi establishment and of the royal
family going all the way up to the Kings
brother who are now languishing in in
prisons and that is really undermining
the social contract if you will between
the surah Sally royal family and the
people I think that the tactical
approaches to obviously to draw as much
attention as possible in the United
States to these high-level individuals I
think the the long game here is really
tied to the upcoming u.s. presidential
election and in the event Joe Biden wins
I think that we can see a wholesale of
releases of high-profile Saudi
dissidents and
members of the royal family President
Trump as we know he has personalized its
relationship with Crown Prince Mohammed
and it is therefore unlikely that any
sort of lobbying well we really sway him
in the immediate to long term but these
developments are unfortunately are only
adding to the already severely damaged
reputation that Saudi Arabia has in the
United States